all right this episode of
congratulations episode 51 is brought to
you by the cash app listen we started
this thing do you want to get paid five
dollars and also give five dollars to
charity right now if you download the
cash app and enter the reward code
Congrats
you'll receive five dollars and the cash
app will send five dollars to the times
up Legal Defense Fund and I think that's
great because I think that's a really
important charity that people should be
in support of and we are here at the
congratulations podcast and uh we'll
talk about cash out later on this show
but download the free cash app for iOS
or Android now this episode is also
brought to you by blue apron blue apron
is leading meal kit delivery service in
the US right now through February 26
blue apron is teaming with whole thirty
to bring you delicious recipes the menu
will feature two whole thirty approved
recipes each week like Mexican spiced
barramundi with avocado had it was great
and chicken lettuce cups with avocado
and kale and sweet potato salad so get
the new year started with blue apron and
whole thirty blue apron is treating my
listeners to the first three meals a $30
value with your first order if you
visibly from.com slash Congrats so check
out this venue and get your $30 off with
free shipping a blue apron calm /
Congrats blue apron a better way to cook
[Music]
so like what's up guys episode 51 the
it's another week in baby film hold my
back not getting any better
pretty cool pretty cool how it's just
getting a little really zero better
every day so that's great and you know a
lot has happened this week and a lot
happens every week now because the world
is so [__] out I I mean you know it
gets it's funny too because when I start
this podcast sometimes I think about how
oh [__] what am I going to talk about
and then I sit here with one fire and
he's like well this happened and then
that leads to that and then we're like
our [__] all these things [__] are
happening and and it's it's the craziest
world we live in man and it's the only
world we live in and we better take care
of it or something you know how they say
everyone's always loved and to be
[__] so so holier than now dude I was
watching a movie called love and the
bullet and I think when people ask me
now what my favorite movies is I'm gonna
say love into bullet and it's with
Treach from Naughty by Nature and it's
funny too because when Treach the movie
juice which kind of put Tupac on the
scene as an actor he was really great in
the movie and I know I think as the
story goes I don't know how true this is
but I heard this I read this it was like
they were auditioning it was Treach and
he went in an audition for the part and
then Tupac went in and they knew each
other and Tupac went in and audition for
this part in juice and Treach knew
hearing through the wall the way to park
did it that he was gonna get the part
because he was just so [__] good and
he did get the part and he went on to
[__] kill the rope you know I'm a
huge Tupac van but
Treach went on to do love and a bullet
and it is tonally my fav
movie because it's a mess it I don't I
don't know I've seen it twice now I
don't know if it's a comedy or not I I
straight-up don't know I'm I'm a
comedian I kind of pride myself on like
knowing if something is taking the piss
out I don't know I I literally have no
idea I posted two clips on this movie on
Instagram elbow I mean I kept rewinding
it laughing and [__] sending it to I
mean Treach is so badass he's so badass
in this movie it's unbelievable and
he'll be like dude you gotta watch this
movie man I mean first of all it
released I actually looked this up last
night it grossed $18,000 night almost
$19,000 she's failure in 14 theaters sit
bad the poster is the worst poster I've
ever seen in my life his legs are spread
so far you know and I mean and he's
being so hardcore dude and like why is
he man Treach loving the bullet Treach
first of all I'm a big Naughty by Nature
fan and treach's from Naughty by Nature
the rap the rap group and they sing they
rap OPP and [__] like that and so Treach
is this guy in the movie that is like
he's like a an assassin and he finds his
girl assassin and he's like I gotta get
out this life man and just make a make a
family with this girl and then the girl
dies but she dies off-screen like and
she never liked the movies about the two
of them she dies off-screen and he's
like she never showed up for dinner
I guess she died or some [__] and then
he goes on and like kills everybody and
they do like breakdance killing like
they do shooting I mean it's so badass
you got to watch this movie
it's like the worst gun safety the worst
gun discipline I mean dude they have the
the guy who was the original Black Power
Ranger
shooting him Treach there's one mover
Treach put plants his palm down and then
[__] kicks his legs up in the air and
shoots and then he I mean you gotta go
on my Instagram and look at this [__]
dude he grabs [__] steam pipes on the
on the ceiling and jumps up on them and
then shoots the Black Power Ranger guy
it's the worst like he'd be dead in four
seconds you know and it's so funny and
and the bet and the one I never when I
was in my when I was watching the movie
there's a scene in the movie where he's
having dinner with his girl and she's
like they're like being sexy talking and
[__] like that and then she and then he
he walks he gets up and walks to the
back of the room and then like starts
unbuttoning his shirt like being sexy
first of all it's so it's just not sexy
when a guy's trying to be sexy you know
what I mean that's the least sexy a guy
could be is if a guy is aware of how
sexy he is right and so he's on buckle
and unbuttoned in the shirt and then
he's like undoing the pants and then the
cutbacks cuts back to her like damn and
then a cut backs cuts back to him why do
I keep saying cut backs
it keeps cut it cuts back to him and
he's fully nude
full frontal and his [__] is out he has
no clothes on and his dick is out for no
reason and it's just a full shot of his
body and he's naked I don't know if it
was his idea
or or if it was in the script that way
or why like the tone of this movie is so
[__] I don't know is if it's supposed
to be funny or earth peelers supposed to
be like oh damn that's kind of like
aggressive and hot that he did that like
if girls were supposed to be like damn
dude it's the funniest movie I've ever
seen ever it's so it's such a shame like
comedians and I and I even comedians we
work so hard to craft jokes and make
people laugh and we will never be as
funny as that movie by mistake that's
the [__] up thing
I would watch that movie I'm gonna watch
it every night in 2018 I mean dude she
dies off-screen she's a major character
in the movie dies off-screen and then
he's like she never showed up I was
about to ask her to it's all voiceover
of course he's like and every voice will
forever feel like every voice ever
starts with this damn you know damn I
guess life isn't the way I turn it I
thought it was gonna turn out maybe I
could have a family but this life keeps
sucking me back in I mean dude what
we're pulling it up right now the naked
shot why the candle lights the light the
candle light and he's oh dude oh and I
forgot the bad guy in it is like just
some guy's uncle he's like the mob boss
and he and at the end of the movie he
starts calling him Treach the n-word and
it's like sad a place he's like oh my
god dude he was like I want you to go
kill somebody
dude you just got to watch it man I
can't I can't I really can't do it I
can't do it justice but it's so [__]
funny
loving a bullet please watch that movie
we got to have bad movie nights I know
we had it once but me and my buddies
including one fire we were gonna have
bad movie night and just watch it we
watch this other movie club but was it
Condor the [__] was it called something
like Condor these movies are so bad
they're better than good movies though
good movies you suck you know music all
in the right place should tell you how
to feel the one thing that uh dude did
you guys hear about what happened in
Hawaii how everyone on their iPhone with
iPhones or phones or whatever they got
alerts that there was a missile coming
inbound and that Dave should take
shelter everybody on their phones and it
wasn't true like whoever hit the button
just hit the button and and it said
ballistic missile threat inbound to
Hawaii seek immediate shelter this is
not a drill
and it wasn't true
emergency update for it there is no
missile threat or danger to the state of
Hawaii
repeat false alarm I mean you know who's
who's in that [__] room Tom Green
like what worst mistake ever dude never
a worse mistake than that somebody just
leaned up against the button also why is
the button so specific how many buttons
do they have that they're like oh this
is the one for the ballistic missile
dude it's so that I would lose nah well
I don't know what the [__] I'd lose my
mind that's so [__] dude I would I I
this video of it online people screaming
and [__] I'm sure I would have I would
have and then they were like just
kidding
sorry and then go back to listening to
Hawaii to Hawaiian music everywhere in
Hawaii dude if you've been in Hawaii I
swear to god they play up the [__]
Hawaiian music so much we get it we get
it were in Hawaii you'll be at a library
and it'll be like being ding ding ding
waiter you can't get away from it dude
you know Walgreens just what by later
yep but I put in a [__] but hot potater
this dancing you know the hula
sob sleep through the hula dancing you
know it's part of the culture here in
Hawaii do the Harlem shake
dab a little bit hey take off the grass
skirt bro put on pants take off that
doughnut of flowers on your forehead and
put on pants you know why the adult also
stop playing instruments that are
completely wooden and I have no idea
what they are so many would dude
Hawaiians will make instruments out of
wood things and it doesn't matter what
shape they are it literally doesn't
matter what shape they are and they'll
just slap them and that's the note
that's the music and then they'll call
themself a warrior
I love how you go to Hawaii and [__] I
was in a luau last time I went to why I
went to a luau
dude it was the worst [__] thing I
ever saw in my life I had to watch grown
man
slapping [__] wooden instruments I
had never seen and they were just like
likkle Allah hater whipple arahida and
then the lady with the plastered [__]
smile comes up and she's just like here
in Hawaii and I'm just like say Hawaii
here in Hawaii this is the dance of the
warrior and then they get all aggressive
and they're like blah blah blah blah
blah blah hula blah blah blah blah and
their cover in the car precariously with
some towels and the girls have [__]
shells over their tits hey get a shirt I
cool [__] you know a shell fall off a
tree and you put it on your tits and get
a tank top zip it up don't wear a hat
that's bigger than you dude you got
[__] leaves on you hey man the only
place leaves should be touching under
your feet dude the second leaves get
above your feet put them back down
we clock Aleli yeah yeah wicked lucky
Laila dude and they're all in unison and
[__] this is the warrior dance imagine
going to [__] fight [__]
with guns and missiles and [__]
with ballistic missiles and they're just
like get the Warriors
here come the missed ballistic missiles
[__] hold on let me get my [__]
leaves we can lock Aleli we palapa Laila
dude cover your [__] here comes the
ballistic missile and it crap in your
face and then PAH they clap in your face
and then bring a [__] shaking hand
back to the back of their head you know
oh did get your grass skirts here comes
North Korea who shoot her mom hey man
shoot him
guys wearin leaves as a skirt kill him
[__] old dead with a [__] wreath
around your head you know and like a
roasted pig somewhere in the vicinity
dude when I was at the luau they were
like come join us eat the roasted pig
and it was like the pigs face now hey
dude make it bacon oh my God look at
what they're doing thinking [__] dude
make it bacon if I could see the animals
face cut the head off dude on the video
podcast we'll show you how it looks like
they're taking shits it looks like it's
so hot on the ground and they keep
hopping Oh [__] did you know
Hawaiians are so good at [__] though
because they care so much do they have
so much passion man who has more passion
than [__] warriors in Hawaii ho ho
hoo hoo honestly nobody has more passion
than somebody who would wear [__]
grass for real the love you know because
you know when Hawaiians [__] they think
about [__] like the Sun you know they're
just like we have a fireball above us I
have to get going
sorry I can't stay the night with the
grass skirt
so long let me get my hat do you know
where we'll up next time I come over
let's watch a movie with the rock in it
take care where are my shoes oh yeah I
didn't bring them so long I'm going to
run home now where do you live 21 miles
away I'll be done I'll be home by sunup
weakly hey Lyla Lyla here meet my Nana
Hannah and then he gets mugged on the
way home oh whoa I'm a warrior and they
just shoot him and he [__] his [__]
flops out of his grasp shirt who got
hurt um dude when I went to why last
time there were people at the airport
and they're like here's a lei and I'm
like get that [__] thing off me man
hey don't put something around my neck
have I ever met you don't put something
around my neck dude do you know my first
name no don't put something around my
neck um I
dude Hawaii bro Hawaii you know that's
amazing it's beautiful man Maui is the
best
I went to Maui and then I went to
another one don't know it's
disrespectful but when did shows guess
if the crowds were rowdy or not yep
Shroud II callin out [__] I literally
didn't know material and just talked
about the people in the crowd because
curtain did the Comedy Store last night
and the night before it dude
the comedy store line up look at this
comedy look at this look at this line up
that is was the other night I think it
was the best lineup
best announced lineup that I'd ever been
a part of now I'm in my eye
iPhone pictures now here's the most
annoying part it goes to memories now I
never want to know about memories hey
get rid of memories cuz I don't give a
[__] I'll remember or I won't I want to
only see the the the what do you call it
you didn't order in chronological order
when it took the pictures okay here's
the lineup of the other night you guys
are missing out I mean I'm talking about
if you're a fan of comedy you need to
literally leave where you are make a
vacation fly to the Comedy Store to see
these [__] liners all right mo mandel
Bobbie Lee
Pauly Shore Tom Segura me bill burr Neal
Brennan Joe Rogan Joey Diaz Jason go
learn Jamar neighbors Mike young Eleanor
Kerrigan Brenton Biddle comb Jack Knight
dombarris pop in Whitney Cummings I
don't know if we can you showed up or
not but those guys right there I mean
any one of those guys is in the middle
you go see for like a hundred dollars in
a theater somewhere and they're all at
the Comedy Store
it's like I don't these other clubs
can't compete man
they're amazing I did it I'm gonna
established comedian I'm like dude I got
a [__] bring it I got it I'm like I
don't even know if like I'm like I don't
even belong here man I say announced
lineup because sometimes you go and
Chappelle and Chris Rock will show up
and [__] and you're like okay cool it's
weird being up it's weird being there
every night when I'm in town and
thinking about how like these are the
guys like Chappelle and Chris Rock and
whoever the [__] else are the guys that
were you know Richard Pryor and George
Carlin I mean these are these guys the
generation our generation these they're
there are guys from our generation and
to be on lineups and [__] with them and
to think about how you know it's like
history dude it's so wild I try to think
about that as much as possible because I
don't want to be you know I never want
to let it get to my head or think about
like you know everyone at the comedy
show is really cool man like the comics
and [__] like they keep it they keep it
cool like there's you know everyone has
an ego but like nobody like lets it get
out of control I mean we all have egos
but like nobody lets it get out of
control like nobody lets anybody [__]
do dumb [__] like it really feels like
we're connect like it's a I don't say
fraternity because that sounds like I
hate fraternities but like our sorority
you know there's chicks there too don't
mean to offend Hey
but I want to talk about that I have
that I might know it's actually but uh
anyway it's just amazing I mean Joe
Rogan bill burr all these guys and then
you're on a lineup with them it's great
I remember when I was thrown into the
comedy store the guy who was the Booker
really like was a fan of mine and like
really wanted to give me the stage time
I had no business going in between these
guys but I will go to like you know I
would go in between like Dove Davidoff
and [__] John capper rillo and just
fight for my [__] fight these guys
would be murdering and they'd be like
give it up for Chris Lea they didn't
know who I was and I'd have to go in and
just [__] try and try and do well and
try and murder at that point I would
just try and murder and yeah it was
crazy man I mean Dov at that point was
like I had never seen anybody like him
I've Davidoff [__] hilarious
you know John Capel rule I never said
[__] three words to the guy but he
never really said three words to me
either but yeah I mean these guys would
murder dude who else was on the lineup
back then that well Sebastian was was
killing Bret Ernst who is [__]
hilarious
you guys got
follow the comedian Bret Ernst the guy's
just great
I don't see him in town too much cuz
he's on the road a lot but guys
hilarious man if you can I'm sure
there's clips of him online the guy says
he's a storyteller and he's just so
funny man I love bread urns I told you
about [__] you guys also got to check
out Nikki Glaser I know that I told you
her about her the other day
but she's so [__] funny man
and yeah so it's great
I mean Brett's face you know on that
thing so what else happened dude you
know what actually what else happened
actually no what let me do these [__]
ads and then I'll get into it yeah uh uh
cash app the cash app is the number one
finance app in the App Store probably
because all of our cult members here
have been switching or maybe it's
because it's the best way to pay people
back friends family coworkers
comedians anyone sending and receiving
money is totally free and fast and most
payments can be deposited directly into
the bank account in seconds new cash
card is a black debit card that you can
design yourself via the app it's really
cool people have been making them and
sending them screenshots to me and
somebody like brand like rights makes
art on it like with the cult and stuff
and like put no bear no Cudas on there
and stuff on their card it's funny it
makes me laugh anyway it's cool it
allows you to cat this cash card allows
you to use the cash that you keep in the
app anywhere you want you'll get
notifications for all payment made with
the card directly via the cash out laser
at your card to personalize it which is
what all of the babies are doing and it
will be delivered directly to you for
free and then you can use it if you
download the cash app now you enter the
code congrats and this is something that
it's really important to us that
congratulations you'll receive a five
receive five dollars and the cash app
will send five dollars to the times up
Legal Defense Fund fund and that's
really cool because it supports women
and their legal defense when it comes to
I mean everything that's been going on
it's just it's just so it's just
terrible and this is a good way to help
so if you are gonna download it download
it and you can help and be a good person
download the cash app for iOS or Android
now blue apron is the number one fresh
ingredient recipe delivery service in
the country Jin know that I cook and I
use it all the time
and it's really good blue apron is a
really really good company that I love
that I will continue to use the food's
all really good they have a variety of
it they send you things that you didn't
know you wanted but you're like oh okay
let me try and you try it and it's all
delicious it's it's all good and it
makes me feel good because I'm doing the
work you know and then they set it up
they set it up easy for you to cook and
you do it and it makes you feel like
you're a chef and you are kind of and
then you can literally be a chef eat the
food and feel good about yourself
because the food tastes good and you're
not eating fast food or you know you're
not ordering you know just food to the
you know at a restaurant it's all you
the blue apron is treating
congratulations with crystal Leah
listeners to their first three meals a
$30 value with your first order if you
visit blue apron com / Congrats
check out this week's menu and get your
$30 off with free shipping at blue apron
home slash Congrats they got the
two-person meal plan family meal plan
they have a wine plan it's really great
just go check it out so blue apron
Beachbody Beachbody on demand is an
online fitness streaming service that
gives you unlimited access to a wide
variety of highly effective world-class
workouts personalized to meet your your
knee your needs
they've got familiar brands like piao
p90x insanity 21 day fix t25 three week
yoga retreat these are all ones that
you've either heard of some of them are
a lot of them but it's great I can set
this up in my house
stream it on TV and get a really great
workout in my house you know I mean I
also go to the gym sometimes but
sometimes I don't have the time to I
don't want to battle traffic so I mean I
recently just got set up with it so I
just I I do different I've done
different courses and they have ones
that really like I like that Shaun T guy
I just like he's passionate and I'm
liking the the focus t25 and but anyway
there's so much variety and it's really
awesome and you know I'm gonna try the
other ones I could obsessed with it and
I want to try the other ones too
so it's really convenient accessible on
your computer when web enabled TV tablet
smartphone or any other web enabled
device so it has nutritional help too
let's not forget abs are made in the
kitchen okay and access to information
on meal prep variety of recipes and
simple but proven eating plans there's
over 600 different workouts so you can
find one that you know is you that lines
up with your interests and goals and you
will find something there so give the
service a try right now my listeners can
get a free trial membership with when
you text Congrats to 30 30 30
that's texting Congrats to 30 30 30 you
will get full access to this entire
platform for free all the workouts and
nutrition information free just text
congrats to 30 30 30 dude how about when
I somebody I saw some comments sometimes
I look at the YouTube comments because I
like to look at [__] lunatics and
that somebody was like you know what you
can tell that he reads the ads but I
still like it oh you can tell it's weird
when you can tell something by looking
at it don't you think I can tell he's
wearing a shirt too
but I like it
Internet
ruining everything but it's also also
also kind of helping everything why is
it ruining everything
um Oh another comedian you should check
out his Michael Kosta I just said it cuz
I got it
we were texting right now but um [__]
hilarious he's on the daily show uh so
um what was I gonna say dude you know
what [__] was crazy this week
actually was the Emily ready to chow ski
thing I'll never know her last name
never wanna I'll meet her and be like
nice to meet you Emily read it to chow
ski Ratatat chatter and all like what's
that fun night at that Tara and all her
scatter what's that [__] anyway oh well
so she good was the third one the third
one right there hit it so excited to she
she got people got upset with this [__]
so excited to announce that I am the new
face of yada yada
welcome to good hair day so she changed
the caption oh man
Double Down [__] she wrote she
wrote um she wrote this thing about how
it [__] oh yeah try this new company
that I love because hair is a
fundamental thing for women's beauty or
some [__] what did she say where
fundamental for femininity beauty and
identity now here's why the internet is
[__] stupid okay so she says hair is
fundamental to femininity and beauty all
right look
yeah there's feminine women that are
bald as [__] sure whether they went
through chemo whether they have alopecia
they can't [__] grow hair doesn't
mean they're not feminine doesn't mean
they're not beautiful okay there are
some beautiful bald women out there
really
and feminine and every people there
people are like you should apologize
because you said this and that hey you
know what dude
it's a [__] ad okay it's an ad in ads
companies say all sorts of [__] that
newsflash aren't true because they want
you to buy the [__] product it's so
yeah look I don't know what it's like to
not be able to grow hair I mean look a
lot of guys are bald gada guys lost
their hair I'm [__] losing mine a
little bit I have less hair I feel like
I you know if it goes and then somebody
is like hey hair you know is fundamental
to [__] masculine [__] this and
that I wouldn't give a [__] I would look
at that and be like oh they're wrong
that's [__] idiots why does everybody
get offended about everything hey bro
roll the [__] on man people are gonna
say so much stupid [__] especially on
the internet you know why cuz the
Internet is everything everybody says
everything on the Internet rolled the
[__] on man
turn the other butt cheek bro
who cares you're sitting at your
computer all day you get offended that's
what happens do other [__] what does the
No
it's just everyone's so offended
somebody said I'd I posted a video from
the from the podcast about how you
should take those what would Jesus do
bracelets and wipe your ass with them
and people are like bro
not funny cross the line hey eat my dick
eat my [__] dick hey eat it touch
your nose to mAb de Minh dig hood come
on man the [__] out of here
who cares shut up go [__] shopping
who cares
somebody didn't somebody commented on a
man it's too you know I die I just wear
it because it makes it reminds me to be
a better person I don't really wear for
shell Oh dude really hey dude he got
problems you gotta wear a bracelet that
says wwww JD to remind yourself to be a
good person hey man change dude what is
wrong with you that you gotta wear
something to make yourself a better
person dude take it off and just be you
Linden then then dude change hey man if
you better looked at Majan being like I
wanna oh man I want to like whatever
cheat on my wife look hold on one second
let me glance at my wrist Jesus wouldn't
do that
never mind [__] go shoppin
[__] do something else man oh
you know what that made me want to wipe
my ass with what would Jesus do
bracelets cuz I'll tell you what if
Jesus ran out of toilet paper and just
had a bracelet that said what would
Jesus do he'd use it to wipe his ass out
of convenience know why cuz he's purse
cuz he's purse it's cuz of the stock
dude don't
[__] offended so much oh man
everyone is so offended hey dude you
crossed the line leave religion at leave
never put God in your act somebody wrote
me once never put God in your act
hey dude [__] yourself see you in hell I
will always put God in my act when I
choose bye see ya get captured become
face the same way Minh sadhya now that's
the most vicious
congratulations combo I've ever done you
CUDA Hey look a shiny bracelet you CUDA
go to [__] Coachella go shopping go
swimming go to [__] Coachella [__]
out of here the [__] out of here dude
never put God in your act
see ya we'll do a SIA do you know we got
to do some be quiet it's what we got to
do you know we practice on with you bud
we're gonna practice touching your top
lip - your bottom lip so we got to do
you fended you're taking to the internet
because the outraged you know what you
gotta practice touching your top lip -
your bottom lip hey men get set with me
cuz it said something on stage that was
a joke and you're coming up to me after
the show to express your pinion and you
outraged you know we gotta practice
touching your top lip - bottom lip dude
hey man your top lip feel lonely let's
join it with your bottom lip it's a joke
you [__] piece [__] go shopping [__]
out of my face man go shopping
ah [__]
ah [__] I love being an idiot
oh man
I forgot about that [__] I had a new
joke and I forgot about it now I'm doing
more got to remember that part I want to
make that an Instagram video alright
just touching your top lip to your
bottom lip that's so dumb how [__] man
was it 38 minutes oh [__] right that
that um [__] one fire hope I write
something [__] up like 42 minutes and
[__] it all up cuz he's one fire I love
how you guys don't know who one fire is
he's like master killer from the wu-tang
you know so what what else what else we
talking about babies what else we
talking about babies it's cuz of the
stock dude thank God for their internet
but also after the internet what else we
talk about babies what else we talking
about how about when Trump was like
[__] [__] all black people or
whatever he said dude how first of all
Trump is that I thought he was racist
but now if there's just no question when
he was just like about what he said
about the [__] whole country's about me
it's not even funny just about all the
Africa countries about why do they keep
coming from [__] whole countries and
then you picked the whitest place and
was like Norway's cool though like could
you be more glaringly racist hey guy
don't be in the White House I don't even
give a [__] about politics man
Republican be Republican Democrat be
Democrat if you're one of the other ones
that doesn't matter be that but dude
come on man don't say that you [__]
dumb [__] also don't be orange you
Simpson man and stop tweeting dude tweet
once or twice a day you know I hope it
doesn't lead us into nuclear war
or any war man what is this [__] ghost
Lauren I think actress Lee is a head of
marketing for this gas station lion face
out lion face ghost Lauren 76 station
damn I like that ghost Lauren that's
[__] awesome ghost Lauren [__] I'm
jealous I didn't think about that
hey guys dude if I was an expedition
Esther would have [__] Lewis and Clark
I'd be like guys time to go Splore yeah
you guys time to do it i love how lion
faces twitter picture is a burger [__] I
saw a guy at the coffee bean today with
a [__] sheer shirt on he had a shirt
that he could see through saw his
nipples
and shorts bro confused oh and I was at
the coffee bean and these two kids came
in and we're literally kicking a soccer
ball and the dad let him do it for like
five minutes and then took the ball away
hey don't bring the ball in the [__]
place the kids were kicking a soccer
ball
in coffee bean against the wall of
coffee bean of a coffee shop
and I was trying to get my [__] head
right for the podcast did those little
[__] [__] know I was trying to do
that no [__] [__] dude I love coffee
man you know what dude I'm sitting
different and here's why I'm sitting
different hello okay cuz my [__] back
hurts dude I'm different yeah I'm
different I'm different
yeah I'm different dude that song rock
bro I'm different I love when rap songs
are like so basic but also specific like
dude I'm different and it was simple
Bing Bing don't think thing done and
then [__]
[__] would be like [__] yeah man
half-hour man you know what I think man
you know girls get upset about like I'm
not a [__] if I thought cuz I want to I
agree I think a [__] is I have my own
definition of it like dude if you're a
girl
you should [__] whoever you want
whenever you want it doesn't go on go on
with your [__] bad self
alright and I respect that and I've had
relationships with girls who have had
sex with lots of dudes and I don't give
a [__] but here's the deal and I've had
relationships of girls who having sex
with them had sex with that many dudes
and I'm fine with both some guys will
get all bent some guy know some guys
that are like oh you shouldn't you know
I want a girl that's pure or I don't
want a girl that's not experienced
either way whatever you know you're
gonna meet who you're gonna meet and
fall in love but I think the kind of
girl that I can't be with is a girl that
pretends she's a certain way that she's
not and that just goes with guys to I
mean I don't date guys but friends you
know like when you don't know how you
are and you're fooling yourself but not
really fooling me I can't I can't get
captured like I read
tweet that on the podcast one like III
can't [__] like if you're a if you're
a Czech and you're like I don't do that
I don't have sex with guys unless I know
them very well
but you do do that who you lying to who
me why to make me think that you are not
a it's not [__] then you're a liar if
I'm with a girl and she's like yeah I've
had one-night stands because I wanted to
[__] cool great good awesome if I was
with a girl because here's the thing I
used to when I was younger I used to be
like you don't make me I was so [__]
such an idiot I was like you don't make
me wait but you would have sex with
[__] some rock star because you know
whatever but you do the long play with
me and I used to be like offended at
that not that I was I'm dealing with
that situation many times but if I was
with a girl and she was like listen I've
had sex with guys on the first night
I've had sex with guys I've done the
long play you know I've made mistakes
I've had great relationships that's an
that but like I I'm interested in taking
things slow with you because I don't
want to [__] it up and I I like you I
think maybe and I'm not gonna have sex
with you the first you know whatever it
is the first [__] two minutes but I
have done that in my life and I wanted
to and now I don't
then I respect that not that you need my
respect but you know I think that that's
that's that's cool you know cuz people
[__] change I get that I mean but
when you're just like no I don't do it
and you do do it and you're gonna do it
again like don't stop you'd stop you're
not [__] fooling you're not fooling
anyone or you're fooling idiots and then
that's who you are you're someone that
fools idiots why what what are you doing
what are you trying to do what are you
trying to gain what what are you trying
to gain
man everybody's so [__] crazy
everybody's so crazy I don't know
dating is weird all my friends and [__]
in LA it's [__] crazy man
it's literally like I you got to be a
rillette I have a real strong head on
your shoulders and know what you want I
mean people are so lost in LA
it's so weird what they're chasing you
know I mean people come and they move
from [__] Idaho cuz they were the
most popular kid and they're like I'm
gonna be famous and they gets thrown
into LA and literally are in rooms with
like [__] the most famous people and
then they're nobody and [__] and then I
don't know I don't even know what I'm
talking about I just I just like like I
don't know it's weird now if you're an
actor you can be like the least good at
your job but still be have like be
rewarded with like it's like the only
job where like you can be so awful but
also be so successful I don't know
another job where you can do that really
you have to have talent with other
things I'm even in the arts like music
like maybe you people get mad at people
say like will pops pop music's [__]
like it's still a [__] skill it's
still a talent it still is art like you
know as bad as some pop music is it like
still takes something like like a lot of
this new hip-hop or rap is [__] awful
but it's still at least a skill to learn
it may not be a hard skill to learn you
know with these all these mumble rappers
but like you still have to make
something sound good and [__] have
people like pop their head to it but
like
acting you don't you straight up don't
use have to say the lines and can be
awful and be rewarded with millions of
dollars in success a lot of guys on
these [__] you know these would
what's the the the C del V would see W
if that even exists you know I mean
anymore like those [__] guys guys who
look like a models that are trying to
like be in comedy [__] like get out of
here to it you go to [__] some of
these casting I used to I don't really
go anymore to auditions like this I
haven't in a while at least I'm sure I
will again but and you get into this
room and you're like oh now I'm you know
when I do audition for something it's
like with other guys I've seen or know
or that are like at my level so or
whatever but yeah I I you know you'd
walk into this room like when I was in
my 20s I walk into the room is his
comedy thing and I'd be like our case I
could kind of make this funny and you're
going and it's like [__] all dudes
that look like Luke Perry in 1990 and
you're like doing the eyebrow thing hey
and you're like oh [__] this guy I'm
going up against this guy and then
that's the guy that gets apart because
he looks like a [__] Ken doll and
you're like and then you watch it when
it comes out you're like oh it's just
zero funny hey what the [__] is going on
what are you trying to do make it go
it's a weird man um it's [__] weird
but I don't know I feel like this
podcast went off on the [__] let's do
Twitter questions do you have any okay
cause if you didn't one fire oh dude you
know what I don't like this guy's
writing me Christopher Dennett act Chris
underscore dens do you do these hurt
your feelings or not that's the thing I
say if I like something I'll be like
I'll [__] that shares my feelings I
percent on the podcast before about
shoes a lot and so their shoes and their
customized shoes that are like that have
that like shark airplane what is that
[__] art anyway why do why do people
paint airplanes like sharks like what
kind of [__] CUDA dumb [__] is that
just have it be an airplane that's it's
way more impressive than a shark
it's in the sky flying you don't need to
make it look like an animal in the water
and and it's customized shoes I don't
like I don't like making the shoe that
you buy your own Nike Adidas New Balance
whoever the [__] you gonna buy shoes
from they did it they figured it out
don't get the shoe and then go to like a
shoe doctor guy that's like yeah I'm
watching me [__] make it a different
color or look at it a different way and
[__] paint some [__] on it see ya see
ya
take him off bury him see ya what else
we got
and so on fire he goes give me a sec one
fire how insecure it oh that's funny
dude
Zach at Zach Crypt Krypton oh no no
Cipriano oh how insecure is it to have a
framed puzzle hung on your wall it's a
very funny that's definitely not
insecure you're using the language wrong
but it's [__] hilarious dude imagine
framing a puzzle well I guess it's a
little bit insecure be like yo I did
that [__] what the [__] is that lady
doing you have to see this Tim Keeley
forget knives is chopping the food with
your teeth the future of food prep oh my
god this girl is not ill she's chopping
the she's not using knives she's at
whatever she's getting Reva Godfrey who
stars in the video using her mouth to
heal butter why would she be doing that
she like will take garlic Matt eat it
chop it up and then spit it out in a
bowl and mix it with what the [__] she's
doing what what we this is what I don't
get we invented knives why are you doing
going
what are you doing going backwards it's
like when people are like hey go Kate
let's go camping and get away from it
all
nah it took us a long time to invent a
[__] toaster and build walls I'll be
inside him the [__] do I want to get
away from all this [__] that we worked
as a human race so hard to achieve now
you want to go near be near a waterfall
what dude you [__] backwards [__]
up dude yeah but let's go out and
[__] sit on dirt
let's get dirt in our nails and anus
somehow nah bro we got air conditioning
you could set that [__] right how you
like it yeah but I want to get away from
it all go in a different room leave your
phone in the kitchen isn't it great out
here you know how do people end it great
out here camping just look it I just
love coming out here and just being all
with alone with my thoughts
you know else is like that crazy people
you're not [__] Gandhi because you
stood near a waterfall just come out
here find myself why does everyone need
to go somewhere else to find themselves
you're right there hey you know where
you are in your clothes I've said this
before the podcast but do it people got
to go to Tunisia to really find
themselves [__] off you really want to
go to one of those [__] countries go
to Norway [__] race racist dude um
I mean know what that is
whyyy [__] you know uh but anyway
how bad is Hawaiian music he won't be
banging Ming ping you know you know what
else is so bad like that
mariachi like Mexican music that [__] is
so bad dude oh the food thing was fake
[__] they got us it was satire damn they
got us they got us no need to get it
outraged for it but yeah how bad is like
that Mexican [__] I mean pimping
[__] Powell Francisco has a funny bit
about that how it's all the same
we're trailing off dude I think we're
done [__] it
alright guys you guys thank you where's
the thing here no elder this week but
will maybe have one next week and
remember square cash have you switched
yet download the free square cash app
and two rewards code congrats get five
dollars and then give five dollars to
time up get it for iOS or Android now
and blue apron check out this month's
week this this week's menu and get your
$30 off with free shipping at blue apron
dot-com / Congrats
subscribe to the YouTube channel you get
to see me in action do this you don't
have to listen to it and download the
Chris D'Elia app for iOS or Android I go
live on there a lot you can just type in
crystally and it'll come up in the App
Store subscribe rate and review the show
and tweet me ask me questions video
episodes go up Tuesdays Wednesdays
upcoming shows I got Pasadena Tampa
Winnipeg Calgary weeks it's got to want
some of those who sold out but check it
out the ship actually they might all be
thank you for listening man and check me
out on the UH the good doctor I'll be on
there
the second set half the season I'm doing
it for five episodes alright guys thanks
a lot
take care
[Music]